no honestly it's really cool that you
can delete so much footage and then like
still like find you don't understand
honestly I'm not I'm not kidding right
now we did this to you because we're
we're gonna delete
so you can [ __ ] learn you're about to
learn a lesson
[Music]
so I want to make sure I say this
correctly because this this new story is
getting misunderstood very quickly uh
Kim Kardashian diarrhea it's for sure
people got that right oh yeah you're
right this is the one that's a little uh
dicey like everyone keeps thinking R
Kelly is guilty like that one like dude
he's not read my boy dude actually
that's probably more important than this
so apparently Isis appears to have
minted their first nft
what is it
talk about mainstream appeal
are you guys
always been in the Forefront of
their recruiting videos were so next
week yeah better than the military they
were super tech they [ __ ] hired
cinematography yeah they had the SE
motivation
that got people of the Western World to
go to the Middle East and [ __ ] jump
ship and join Isis wow do you think
there's a bunch of Isis dudes who are
like hey when men when men when
utilities
everyone like GM GM yeah
they're even using the [ __ ] slang or
there's an Isis Channel where they just
say gmgm
oh Jesus
now like what is it versus destroy them
yeah what is it a shell you know
sometimes like brand design that comes
back as like a licensed form of what is
it like this is it like the same Isis is
it the same owners it's like Hostess
yeah exactly and what's the relation to
the Taliban they hate the Taliban they
all hate each other Al-Qaeda they all
got big houses I'm glad you brought that
up because that's kind of what the nft
is about it's shooting on the Taliban no
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] recently Isis
successfully uh carried out an attack on
Taliban uh soldiers in which they bombed
the vehicle of theirs and killed like I
don't know like 12 people or something
it's like some crazy thing but the
announcement of that action was Minted
as an nft
so the headline so they're basically
record the bombing no it's just it's
just a hey we did this and that's the
form in which they put out the news
oh is it on ethereum sorry like you can
bid on it on Open Sea
who knows yeah who knows but then
because of that now there's like a
growing fear that they're like oh the
terrorists are going to start using
blockchain against us wow it's like
causing a stupid hysteria about
blockchain technology yeah
can I at least convert it to Avalanche
do you love Avalanche
really
it's a card Donald Guy
maybe
okay I'm just used to it because yeah
yeah I'm really used to the cosmos
ecosystem how did you guys get so into
Terra Luna
there's Steve oh I had a dream yes
a lot of Koreans have that dream too I
was following Luna um since it was like
50 cents uh December and it got in at
that at that price I didn't buy it yet I
bought it five well five bucks yeah five
bucks but I was following it like the
December before yeah like it started to
go up yeah and I man I I just every time
I used it because I downloaded Terror
station like that the utility was
amazing yeah I know the idea of actually
it made the most sense right just even
House of Cards like the way that they
could take it down yeah it was just yeah
well dokwon gave them the way he told
them he was too good
was also problematic yeah to say the
least yeah yeah he's also a very bright
guy yeah also Tara's not dead either
like like they're back they're still
turns back everybody
like everything classic they're still
building not that I really you know it's
it's I just miss using the ease of use
that Tara has for Christmas you can just
get on there easily move money around
you can use Wormhole Bridges you don't
even have to worry about it but they
didn't think that they didn't have to do
which is they went back they didn't fire
the team and we're getting staking
rewards from you know all the [ __ ] that
went down like they could have just did
you know we're objectives yeah [ __ ] it
yeah we're vested we have to pay
attention to their ecosystem because
we're going now you invested yeah how
often do you guys talk about crypto and
nfts on this show every episode
um whenever Steve comes down for sure
for sure
that's a great question Bart are you I'm
glad you're asking that I have a little
bit here and there well actually like
nfts no no recently I sold everything
um just because it seemed like
everything looked kind of scary but I
had a little bit of Luna at Bitcoin
ethereum and then I sold everything and
no nfts no nfts now I just don't I don't
feel like if I don't have a um like a
visceral reaction to something I try not
to yeah invest in it because I just
don't even know what it's about totally
yeah
I got some dragon eggs dude bro you got
dragon eggs
nfts are like mostly it was mostly Tara
and cosmosis for me I'm all straight up
don't I don't give a [ __ ] about utility
what is the margins that I'm gonna be
making what is the ROI here yeah how
risky is it bam I'm in he doesn't even
care about the wrist he's like oh the
risk is that high I'm in yeah lower some
of your big ones there's times he gets
pitched crypto right and then he goes
bam 100 G's baby oh my gosh hey Steve
what was that about again yeah yeah yeah
Joe just like I'm like okay here's the
play I'm like if we can get it low low
low low means like you get like
basically at the Ico price right then
that'll be really sick because we'll get
like a we'll get to stack a bunch of
multiples well it comes out everybody
front runs it hardcore right so yeah
time that you could buy it it was
already five bucks
100 Grand in after it's high like that
was not the place
did we did we do it or what and I'm like
no man you definitely did something I'm
like yeah I stayed up late but I didn't
do anything
tell me that part though yeah bro you
didn't give me a Target there's a flaw
on your device Target no he fell asleep
during it I did yeah so that's why I
felt no no but then remember it didn't
show up on the wallet you couldn't buy
the purchase yeah but I didn't buy
anything that's what I'm saying well you
didn't tell me that
[Applause]
[Laughter]
let's get it in early is all I heard so
I'm like all right let's apply and no
one said Mission abort dude it worked
out though it all worked out it worked
out yeah it worked out it all worked out
it worked out because we both lost a
million so yeah
that's friends that's friendship it
wouldn't suck if only one of you lost
yeah exactly that would have been bad
in retrospect none of that [ __ ]
matters because what matters is if you
keep the money what matters is the
community and the friends you made along
the way
I had so much fun with you guys during
that time yeah so based on based on that
definition then the Isis stuff matters
more than your guys's thing because that
has more of a that's more of a community
involved yeah yeah for sure dude that's
why Steve's worried about the road map
telling you what is the road map like
what do I get for buying this mmt yeah
you really do become part of that
Community
their Discord must be exactly yes what's
happening there's basically going to be
a file on you very extensively from that
point on
you get to vote like who they bomb next
and [ __ ] like that I don't know I don't
know
who do you want me to bomb Nick but the
one one of the main things they're
afraid of and I don't know if this even
applies is they they're afraid that
propaganda that gets put out out through
nfts from terrorist groups because it's
on the blockchain it will never be
deleted so there's no way to take stuff
down oh that's what they're afraid of
because like now if something goes up
and everyone's like no that's wrong
that's not that's not true then they can
just like you know
propaganda is everywhere right and the
internet never forgets anything exactly
yeah it's already there yeah it's
already that but that's what they're
saying they're afraid of because of that
at least jihadoscope which is like a
company that watches and tracks jihadist
activity that's what they're that's a
great name
no I didn't even invested a fellow
Korean I did I didn't I didn't I'm not
I'm I'm not actually invested in a lot
of those coins it's just it's more just
straight up Bitcoin it's not that I
don't believe I'm I really don't have a
strong stomach for that stuff I'm not
good at that side of trading like D5
that's like it was never my thing do you
still got Bitcoin with you um
you got it in early early no you're like
20 no and I'm constantly I buy
constantly like weekly like I'm still
like yeah nft Community has more like
artsy and designer types yeah whereas
like the crypto Community has more of a
just like Finance exactly yeah that's
why I think crypto different kind of
personality I think I was always
resistant to crypto because I'm allergic
to those two streams Tech and finance
like those are two Realms that I wanted
nothing to ever do with because I'm from
like arts and culture so nfts were the
first time that it spoke to me because I
understood our culture Community like
that stuff was my language so I'm like
oh I'm I can get this and now I learned
it backwards right now I'm doing all the
I'm learning about the Rest In Reverse
so it's an interesting it's
mainstreaming crypto more because people
I think have a broader appeal when it
comes to Art like everyone can
appreciate art and music yeah they get
their favorite musicians are getting
involved they're like oh this is crypto
doesn't feel like it really and if teas
were more
yeah for sure Uber rides multiple times
and had guys in there with like nft
placards and [ __ ] yeah advertising for
nft projects yeah
dude that protest that uh that we did
that was genius did you guys see that
the nft protest so we did and uh the nft
NYC is a conference that happens twice a
year and most of the projects the Big
Blue Chip projects they got they spend
millions of dollars on activations
yeah so I was like what can we do but
that's like God Hayes nfts was like a
very streetwear minded thing we used to
do God hate Street where we you know and
just these ridiculous campaigns yeah so
we were like what if we had failed
protesters so we went on Craigslist you
know hired people
and then we printed out these posts it
costs nothing cost like a thousand
dollars overall instead of spending
millions of dollars on an event dude so
we just did that and it made me more
noise than anything oh so that's the
funny thing is that there was an nft
right after we did the whole protest
someone went out and started making nfts
of those and it's like Rick and Morty
saw we didn't do that oh you guys didn't
do that no but then they started
claiming it and this is like the nature
of the internet and truth and real news
and we're not they started claiming it
and saying oh no we did that and at
people who were there in like our
community and everyone within the nft
the the actual nft Community they knew
they were like oh wait no the hundreds
was doing that for Adam Bomb Squad and
then this other collection came in was
like no that was ours and I just kind of
like Let It Ride where I was just like
you know what [ __ ] it like if that's
what you want to claim we have other
things that we do constantly so it's not
a big deal to us but it is a funny thing
that ha that's very crypto yeah but
anyways yeah we did not campaign that's
so cool it was fun so that camera is
really fun was it foreign
we had a pop-up shop and I just wanted
to bring people to the pop-up shop and
then to Drew a crowd yeah and then we
knew it was going to go viral it was the
first thing that happened that whole
week and so the entire week people were
like oh you guys are great I think it
was real yeah
most people thought it was right on the
street still yeah and then just like on
the internet when people are passing
around social they're like you know and
then if they were four nfts they were
like look at these idiots and then if
they were against them they were like
finally yeah I'm with these people yeah
and then I'm just like that's what we
made the shirts we had Billboards in
Times Square last year that said nfts
are a scam
many of those shirts our whole Community
walks around and says nfts are dead nfts
are a scam and people walk up to you all
the time and they're just like yes or
they're like I I yeah I agree nfps are
the worst I spray painted on the side of
our wall inside of our office and there
was a guy in the in there the other day
that was that we'd hired like a
contractor he was working on stuff and
he came and he's like yeah I [ __ ]
hate that [ __ ] it's such a skip I love
you guys for it and everyone was like in
you know
again they're like literally working on
nfts they're just like yeah you know the
community sentiment is so down that I'm
just I just participating that
especially on this show I'm always like
oh yeah crypto's dead we all died on it
we got killed yeah [ __ ] but bro I am
excited as [ __ ] yeah same obviously I
keep like doing it because I'm like this
is great well you got to be able to
laugh at yourself like yeah yeah because
so much of it is entirely insane and
ridiculous like what we're doing it's
insane like invisible money that you
know invisible pictures that we're all
passing and we're believing in these
things what are we doing this is just
like exciting it's it's humans we're
just we've done this since the beginning
time we did it with religion we did it
with government politics and laws and
customs like it's all just made up [ __ ]
that we all at some point decided you
just have to get enough people critical
mass to Believe In A Thing and then it
becomes the truth that's what I love
about it right so yeah the people who
who believe in the old fake thing yeah
the Federal Reserve exactly they're
saying how fake all this [ __ ] and I'm
like what yeah do you not see what's to
happen 10 years ago and they're still
they we never even fixed that we're
still doing the same thing my uncle's
like we'll just back by and I'm like
yeah dude what's the [ __ ] dollar back
yeah they don't think go to the bank and
like pull out your cash right now these
are so clever with that [ __ ] it's like
yeah dude good luck man yeah everybody
goes and runs on the bank guess what's
gonna happen and the same thing with
nfts when they're like oh this isn't
like why would people pay this much
money if I'm like do you know what it's
like in the art world like go into the
Blue Chip because we collect a lot of
like physical art also I'm like if you
think this is crazy go over there and
people are buying that for 100 yeah and
hundreds of millions of dollars on
institutions are behind that [ __ ] in
museums and you go and visit those
museums and you think that that's worth
you know it's Priceless because so and
so believed it that's all it is it's
just I think it's an auction house
inflation of prices too and yeah that's
all wired and all those people are
making money along the way and the
artist is making nothing and so it's
like that's always been a part of the
system dude the Mona Lisa is whack
dude
[Music]